welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the Clown
Prince of YouTube and what's better than
one Joker movie that's right - Joker
movies so today we have an official
announcement from Warner Brothers that
they are now working on a follow-up to
their billion dollar movie at Joker when
the film was first announced it was said
that it would be a standalone story
however many people including myself
were desperate to see more and I guess
money talks because going forward we are
going to be getting a follow up as well
as another project from Phillips that is
centered around a DC property for the
last couple of weeks Joaquin Phoenix has
teased that he would make a comeback as
the character and this is great news for
fans of the film that want to see more
from the topsy-turvy mind of Gotham's
most infamous villains Joker is the
first-ever r-rated movie to hit the 1
billion dollar mark but it also had a
vast departure from the standard comic
book movie affair presenting a dark and
extremely great movie that had many
people calling for Phoenix to receive an
Oscar for the role now interestingly
this announcement carries a lot with it
there are rumors that the upcoming
Robert Pattinson and Matt Reeves Batman
movie will be set in the 90s and if that
is the case and I can imagine the studio
wanting to tie the two properties
together so we finally get Phoenix's
betrayal face off against the new dog
Knight himself though we don't actually
know what the second movie that Phillips
is working on is it could potentially be
a crossover film or perhaps even another
origin story for one of DC's other
villains
either way I'm so glad that this is
going ahead as I've been hoping and
praying for a follow-up for the movie
because something about it just stuck
with me okay I guess it was all those
murders that have caused remember
remember when all those murders happened
after after people went to see Joker no
oh yeah yeah me neither
anyway I can't wait to see when this is
finally released in what could
potentially be 20 22 and it looks like
Warner Brothers are starting to go ahead
with this new vision and it could end up
being the new universe that they carve
out after their current one has been
quite hit and miss now obviously I'll
keep you up-to-date with news on the
project as it comes out but in the
meantime I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this and
if you're excited for the movie comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of the Joker clock theory
which explains why all of the clocks in
Joker are set to 11:11 I'll be linked at
the end and it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey will head
over to my discord server which should
be linked in the description below we
drop videos on there early so if you
want to see stuff before anyone else
then that's the best place to be it's
free to join and we have an awesome
community so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the Marvel phase 3 part 2
boxer on blu-ray which contains Black
Panther and Benny War endgame Captain
Marvel and more and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the Joker sequel in the
comments section below the winners gonna
be chosen on the 15th of December and
the set will be shipped out from the
intro if I get surprised it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]